[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
lord king david of iron lord podcast and
also of darth castle x
i'm here to bring you new and great
information a lot of guys wanted to get
into statue collecting
and i found a way to actually get you
guys in so
we'll be raffling off brand new statues
on darth castle x fridays at 9 00 pm
so what i would like for you to do is to
get in contact with me
so you can get into one of the raffle
slots
we have 14 slots left this week and
that's for the black cat
xm studios black cat is a phenomenal
statue
is along the spider-man lines and every
week we'll be raffling off
a new statue in the xm studio
line please get on board
the statue is worth upwards of a
thousand dollars
and you can only uh
you can buy up to three tickets
and they're 25 each and it's a live
raffle
get your number everything is raffled
automatic in the computer
and you win statue is shipped to you
you don't pay any taxes you don't pay
any shipping
the only thing you pay is 25
for a chance to win a statue that is at
upwards to a thousand dollars
so happy hunting guys and
reach out to me in my dms so that i can
give you the information
take care have a happy holiday
[Music]
you